foreign
out right there
you're falling out
you have to get the physical level first
okay
so uh right here
you go one hand
and then you do the edit
your hair
right right when we
already have them right on both hands
they say both hands both hands have you
feel that okay so both hands have
if the hand that's yielding isn't
getting out of the way and letting him
fall in the hand that yields positive
into adhesion
and the hand that is going to do the
Yong isn't waiting
so uh
remember the
Yin aiki yield
has a young component do you feel that
so what watch how you're pushing you see
you're pushing and you can't push in
there's nowhere to go you see until I
make the adhesion and then I move you in
right so this hand isn't
waiting but it's going to it's going to
ultimately go young you see that but it
is bringing you in so for example take
this hand out and you see this hand look
where you're going
do you see
so it's not here waiting and doing
nothing this kind of you're just
yielding collapsing
okay so the two heads right at contact
fields are generated and then I move
those things together
and half the other bodies will die later
okay no already in
that this is the drill so in other words
at an energetic level when he when he
goes turn over you need time then boom
I've done the Drone
boom
boom they say your little body you see
your body moving a little push so don't
don't not push or push oh
I'm turning the content field home
it just Carries On
[Music]
but at the physical level there's no
waiting here here pushing okay
okay and then likewise as UK
as he goes around to it so you you feel
that okay there we go that's it right
there and then here I don't see
this collapse
I leave it on and he turns it
so we establish it
there it is and I leave it on and I let
him turn
you see that you feel go off
so
on and I let him turn my field
okay you gotta get that physical level
first okay let's go
so uh let's see uh play some art
s
do uh normal what you call normal
this little keep going as I'm talking
this will turn right in there that the
good kids doing where Chris was breaking
Center ago you say that thing it's
okay uh this is the wrong wrong thing
and now that we do the this other
variant we see you cannot access it
because you were not doing the right
thing okay and you break Center where
you feel your balance goes you try to
get control again and then you're just
staying ahead of the curve okay but then
you're letting her okay
so this technique
uh on the normal cookie Dosa he he's not
going to uh do that little turn do you
see that little turn
get it it's it's more forward roll do
you see
you understand because if you had if you
had this hand and this hand is going
that way do you think
how in the world can he turn
okay
so his hands going that way
[Music]
do that little turn
it's very weird okay so now what we're
doing is we're just uh taking
for your level of Tristan this this uh
tonden field and we're going to do
Aquino nagada so you're going to make it
do the whole pattern instead of half the
pattern you get it so
this one is going to double up so he's
going to end up turning around so up is
this way
you see that
it's not tenchy Noggin
he's going to turn around
and I'm just turning my time
inside me turns his condenser up right
here we're connected we're both doing it
and I turn mine
he turns his
because I'm turning
this is different
different
okay
again if okay
generates the tandem field
and then lets their field be turned
they'll go that way okay like you see
like he's watching your Alaska where
you're like whoa
and then you're you're not you gotta let
it happen okay